TINGFIGH
THEAT WCH OFES RTHI TS
PROG
MRAINE ONLOKTV @BORG
IC
CL THE AER WORAPDS TO T
ND A AHISNDRELL PSVIOU
ODEPISES
.
GNOFTD AERELNDON A W
EV TYBODOS THIFT AONERNO
'SR
ARAPROGMT TEAOMMO CNWHLT
CL
MYEAM IST ROBER ROSTHALEN
I'
AM BRDOAEM MR ABEND
NGME JTRNALOUISNDRINT P A
NOE
CE
IERNT FORTIGANVTI
VE
REPO
EA CRIE MY DEEARR I
WIK
INHI PADELALPHI WE WEREOT N IN
AMTHE SAP NEEWSPUTER B WE
SCREMINIBOUTED PECELAS W
ILIVEDNLLY PHI.
UDININCLGESES CHEAKTES.WI
OUTHT HOIERC ETSFFOR A TTHE
AMAL HERDE W MIGER NEV
WN KHAVENOW K WENOBOAY TOD AUTJE
YFFRETE EPSIN.
WH
YMYSTERBOUT AEY JEFFRPS EIN,TE
WE KNEW MOREBOUT AIS HMS VICTI
HE
THEF
SDICIJUALHATEMYS TVE WEN E
R
DSE BECAU IT'S INTI REPORNG.
SE
BADN OEP RHETINGOR TEW N
EP
ASEISTN W R TEAELSEDKSHI WEE
EFFRETH JTEIN EEYPS RATTA SRT
E
REATHAT'MDSORRY S SO T
AYIT
N'SOTTION FICUT B ITS
I
UETR.IT
LIKEA RDS AE NOVEL.
ONL NISOT S AY ABORYTOHATUT W
IT
RYEALLAK TES TO BERE GAT
ATSTINVEIGIVETIEP RORNG ITS
PA
SSIN TION,AK,ISG RKS
ALESNG A,E SINGL
AF
HIINGDO T O KINSDFOR WK,T' IS
SABOTOUT WHATNE HAPPE
D
SPE NTHEWUSER IAPND
Y ITRN
FRMSTE OTS I DGNSOWIZIN.
D REALT'SLY ABOTO SRY A
UT
THE AEOL OFSI PRENCDEY.
PEELE LIK JULIE TND AHE
MI
ALIAM HER WHA DDIDY D TTHE
IU
ITAKLYES A DIFEREFENC.
I'M
SOED TON HOR BEERE H
TODA
NDYND H IHLIGYMEEC ROM
BOOTHIS A FKORDYR MIA OF
S.ASREN
EEFSO BORE WP JUM IN Q AUICKNO
BOTE AUTAY TOD'S F,ORMA I
AMRLCUARTILAED PLEYAST THA
TOP
RY IDATSRESEEPNTONEY M
CO
THONWEMMAL CLUIRST F
BR
HYAL VIRIDTUSROGR PAM
NE
NEUB OCLPEER EARDLIHIS TONTH.
RSTHE FIN ITS I
AN
FRSCCIO.
S AEWVIERUNROD THERY COUNT
NGWATCHIIA VBE YOUTU.
OFALLOOU Y NR HAT MTE
OWYO
REU' WATINCHGOU CLD SMIUBT
ESTIONHER ESIT JIEULR O
ME
'R YIFOUINGATE WCH OENLIN
EAPTHEN
ORATE CH F Y OMATFBEOUTUR
ZUMA.
EOAS T B TUG BROHT MOE
RO THOUTHEAMRO PGR.
EON-SIT QSTUEIONS ME W A
EN
WHROHE M TICERONESPH W
E
LL.WE T OHE AIENCUDES
CA A WILSL WO BLSENDTTENRI A
T.
AVEI' HADOT L OFVI INTERSEW
WI TWOAV DID YEAORS T R
TESO
HERANT W TO FEA RD THEMRO
ACEPREF YN IOOKROU B ITS
RE
L B WITILKING TEALBO AUTOD TAY.
T IUGHTTT JUS S UP
BUT
REWE ANG DOI.
WLIJUEROTEHI TS IN
THEEF
PRACE.
THY O ISNL ATT WRIEN FEW
NT AGO CAM OUTS THI
EKE
JEPSYRE ERYIN STETO
IZIOLOOMATN
YSIDEDPS SMTE OF J
TIUS.
TIISTH VICFMS OUA SEXLT ALSSAU
ALESPECI W TLYHOSEOU AHORE YNG
AN A PDOORRERD DISCA,EDHA S
DIC
BYDEARDERYHE T VEOPL P
EAR
OSEDSUE PP PROO TCTTEM. T
EINEPST GOTIT WHIS C H
MERIS
BELY ENEE ARRYVENTLE EME
OCIEOF S ALLTYEDOW HIMO TET GAW
AYH WIT IT.
PR,ONESSIALEG LAL,OR MAL
WHIETCS SEREETORDE ASI F
ENBR SD
PEORACI
EAONALRS WITH, PLTOL
ICTYSO
COTIONECS ANDRI CELEB
MEHE T MTOS'SEA TCH AND
MOECY IAC BE AAM
LIJOURNATI'SST WRI
NG
INJU WESIC FORT CHOANNO
FFIGHTORMS THEVEELS.FE
PLE PWEO SMEE TOOGNI RECZE I
WO MACD FETA OANYBS
ICN
TATMY PHHEO T TRUTH.
OF O OFFFIN EPSTE'S CMERI
BY
OME S OFHO TSEOU YE'V BEEN
B TINHIS FINUSESS AOR. WHILELI
G EKEVERYATREEE STR HTAS
A
BEI
INNNG.CA
TAK YNOU TO UES THE POI
FIR YEOULLY RSTEAOT G
HOWHER
EDOKN O DOU YNGOIS THI STORY
OMAND S I VEENTSDY ATLREA
IRTRANSP YOU M OR N MAYOT
LRO
I>>NE LAT 2601 I WAS IN
HE T
FDDLEMI OTE LON AG-
RM
VE IATIOIGNONTRI FLODA
RT
O MTOOVE TNONGOM SETHIO
DIFFTEN.
RGI SURNGRCESEAH O
CKAFTRFINI.
ER GE TIM IEDOOGL THO TWO
BJSUEFTS,EC JEYFRIN EPSTE
'S
MEP.PEDOP U
IDEA AN CNEY B O OF OUR
C,
ATTOLLYEA SRI THEOD CNAMIL
JU
YSICSTE S ANDTE THE
OS
PRTOUTECORS ORAS TK F
EY
THAN HDLED IT.
NOHAINTHG T IT RDEA SOMEEED T
KES
MAFSEEN O IT.
A WHEAS MANED OCC AUS
MOG CSTLEINLEOUSSIR GLS
DAME S HEEE GD TETH WIT A
AP
SL T ONHERI WST.
I
US JRT STTANGICED PKI AY AWAT
IT
NGOO, LKI ATT,ST REQUE
INE
SO RUBLI PCONORDEC D
TRAT NOMPINED A TAN M BOEALUM
SAB LORRE SECRYTA.
I WAS A MREWA --NTEA TY BTHATI
A IME WASSTREWA ACOASA
THECU PROSERTO T FORHE
MINEIGF
ROISECUND SRTO A
FN O TSHIS THI DLE PA FORLEA
EINEPST.
LLIT REAHT BROYUGFUCH MI
UP
.
WLEAR C FROM LHAT TTLEIT
TY DHEIDIO QUEST
HIMN
HEOUTAB TOT DIDY NND USTERAND
SCE OPE ORREADTHHIF O T
HO DEAIBRRLET A TLHAD
OSCCE
OFFGNSIEDN.
>>RE AKING TAL AUT A
.
EAT ITHSRSHT YIGEAHEFTER A T
AL
DE,IG RHT?
ISN B ISEEIN LAYGMA DORNT
TEIFOR GHOURS YEA YRT STAPO
I AKINGTTGA AIN.
BTSEECAU INE WAS O OFHE T
NS
SI I WOU READ ARY STOND A
YWSA
HOS T DIDHIAPPE HN?
OFRIHE S TA
SHT
APULDCO HN.PETHIOMNGEIK
WIASUR CIOUSUT ABO
THAT
CTFA.TH
T WENHENSHI NNINOMATIO
EDHAPPEN IHT THOUG I WONDERAB
HETOU TMS FIC VTIORS THI I
S
AGT HEMREEND TPEAPNERS
YEA
THEFOBEREMS WIC VTI INEERN O
EIR
TH 20sAT LEAR ELY 3
.0s
THEOR LAB STAECRERYAS WNE O
VETHM
TR AINFICKG LHIND CLDABOR
LAWS
.I
DONDE WREPSHAT W EIN'STE
VI
IMSCT THINK TBOUT AANSHI M
O
WHLL AEDOW THEIRRREDA PTO
MO
AL OFFST T HOOK NOW
AG
ER TOVHEFEI RNS OHI TS HUGEDE
.RTPAMENT
>> HHEOOK FOR YOU W
HITEM
ANDTHPAY CIONPAOMSS
THIN
BOUTNGKI AOUNGHE T Y
ON
HOWAND HEY THT MIG BETING SITTH
HINKEER TBOUTGIN AT WHA WAS
G ON TF IREYHE ARE AWA
F O
OSTAATWH CONEAD H DN I
ER S
TING COFUTIS H PLEA DEA AND
LE
PSGTTIN EOS ATEINLMTK WAL.
ILS AOAW S HE HADLREA ADY
RV
SE TEDHEHORT SL JAI
NTAD HECE HIVEEN B G
EN
NYANY M YRSEA BEIOREFE B
LE
REEDAS 2 INE900 HT WEN BACK
JTO HISETET SNGTI LEIF AND
OG
OCKBA T HISDAYVE ERYIF LE ANDMA
ONEYNGKI MOBNOND A H
INBBI
THE ATHLLSEORTA IMPNT
.
OPPELE
IN MY M'MIND IHINKINUT AGBO
S THI
L NAREOT TIVINHEIFE SAM L
EEY
TH. L HADED
IN MYD MIN I G IN K
TLT TFEHA GUTNC INSTI TY
RETI SLL P SBABLROYFERIUFNG
TR
MMA FAUROHI TS.
>> ATOIHIS T PNT FROMHE T
FCOURTNDINGIL ATSOC DUMEN
E
AROKLOING AT, HADOU YEG B
HUIN SNOURCND OGRKI LOO
NG
AN WHADIEANGN WTAS OHE T
CO?E
AOIHAT T P INT WASKI LOO
NG
DDINGEAHE T DTS.UMOCEN
ASIT W A OLDER VY CASE.I
OOKIAS W LORNG AOO HUIK QTE
Y.
OF
ORONREAS F IKI LOONGAS ANTO C
ET
THTS T IHA. OLD
WID COINCTALENE HAS W
MIHTD RTEIGN T OHE I TIME
WA
G POKSINT A IT.
ALSOAW S WHERE TNEAS O
WS
LAIMT AUI SSUE LPLAW
TT
WAS STILLGERI LINNG I WONDEDRE
WHY IT WASGING HANN O
FT AR
F TLAL O YHEEARS
A>>THI TNT PSOI YID DNOOU KW
AMW
ERE WHEY THELL AE JAN DOES
INER
F THE
G?ILIN
TANLLRE A JEOE D
AK>> TE USGH THR, YOUOT G
TSOUTYON
WTHINMEGNGROERE H.
YOAVE H YOURNOOK H I THE U.S.
EYATTORNICHO W BAS LETAL
ISTH GUYFF O
.
HETSOC DUMEN
OU Y'RE
AOKLOING'S TTHERE OOZ DENSFYO
GUN WENOM ALLOREDEG F THE
TECTIV FOU HESADE
WNDER
TOINGOGFY TES TTIEANTYHE M
ALLYSEXUDBU ASE BYEYEF JFREP
WHEEISTNN WHE TYINOREER M
S
THAIG RHT?
T
>> C IHATS
CTORRE.
H OEN DOZSASF CESS I NOT
WOE, T,EE THR,R. FOU
IE BIELVEE
R
T T>>HA ISHT RIG.
ERAS WNF I IMATIORON TN
HEI
FBE LIT ATLFIT B O FBI
INNRMFOATIO WE HADHEAS W TBI F
AGENER WETI INVESTIGANG IT,
OR I IESERTEDN TVERALING T
O
WNEOR YK AEWND NICO MEX
HIH
WO OREWE TLACEERTH PE
WSER
N OSTEPEIEDWN HOMES.
ITEOT SID D N WAYHY WAST I
EA
CLROE M WERHETHE H HAD
ABEBE
HEOTE
OU>> Y HAV AUA SITRE WTIONHE
FSW
EMENFOA
OE C
T WORENNG ALO THIIT WH
S?OBAB
PRERS OLYTHIGHTAVE
ENBE ORAUTGED.
WH STEHE WN DIDOU Y GO
FORLOOK
CH R>> IEAED-UT O -AKE M ONE
OTHTHENGS TERHIICED N IOT
T IT M OOSTF MYAR CEERHE TABOU
RS
POLICE.ITNG THOUG THTHE
W THEAS LDEA D TECTIETVEEN
ARSYE A?GO
WASHE TOL PICE CEFHI?
AN
D DOING R MESRCEAH THE
ED
ETEDECTIV CF O THE
EAS HAD
ITIREREDHEIDNSE TIC POL
E
CHIEIK MER WRITE.
THEYES, NEV HYADPOERKEN
ICLYPUBLLL AT A AHEUTBO TASE C.
H
EA YRSVEGN
IEEARLR.
IHII TNKNE LIK
010. 2
ERESETH W D EVEEN
INNDIEWSRV AHEY T WEERRT COU
DE
SSITIPOONSHICH W A
PRWLY KABNOTTRE P ARE
YYOB
RIUMENTS.
I OUTETEALL RY TIR FSTORY T
TO GETHEM T TO GO ON RORECD.
>> HHI TSVERS CON ISIOATN
NO
TTOOE TNS IIDEWSRHE N
WH R IAT'MLLEAYG TRY TIN
OTH
WRO HERUT OES I ANE O
RE
, ORTPOERNENER PSOS WHO I
T
GUTSTI INSNCAS INSIONND A
GU A ANDY VERGTR SON
L WIL
LY TCANRUE MAK A DE.REIFFENC
HEUS
LI.
IT
POEVER N SN OKEN THEOR REC
D
TSE AEN DOCUMTHE TN
COCIINNG TROMHE PHEBLBAY TIR
N CISMNIAS W THAT PRO
AND
H LGON DIDHAT TAKE? T
TOOHA TTOT L AK L THAGEONRN>
CTEXPEED.MY
WTO EDIRAS GNGETTI AEIT LTL
TS IAU BECSE TAST WGAKIN SO
NGO
I WAS TOINGRY T EHELAINXP T
SET
VIESS NIMAMOTERE W NN A INY
T
OFHEUMENTS.
IT'S AAI PTAKIS
OU.
IDATWH I D A I SRTTAED
RE
INADG EGRYVETHIN.
HIINDOG T S ASS IDAI FOR SO
MANY IRSEA ITTA ISNEVI
THEY
IS MSHE TE NAM O TYHE
HOT N
IRSTHE T F ANDAM NE
ASTETH LAM NE.
AAS W BIGUZ P IZLE A DID
REBOTSHEE A
HAUT WT
IORMINFOAT O HN IADACN EH
I VM.ICTWO
YD OULNLCR BAP OFS
ATINFORM.
FRROHOSE T PORSS ICENFTIONMA
I
AOOKE LDT SEOM OHEF TSE
WO
N HMEAD SUED ETEPSIN TREHE
IS AHAINEDUT O, ONEE JAN GO
TOA
W TLLHE UPAY TO 120
INMESOT.
UL YOUOC SIALED MIA IF I
FO
DUN ONE WNANOM OEB FAC
OOT'
LESUS JT SAYE JANICTH SMI
REAITLLY KFDIN OEP CREY AT
TIME EEC BAUSEASTEPSIN H
A
CERT O KNINDFYP TE.
DE HBLONR,AILUE- BEDEY,Y THE
OKED
LO VERYARIM SIL.
ATOOEY LKIR THEEN FRIDS A
NL
OWEGTLY I BOAN TCE PIE
TO
ERGETH.
TH L JUSTW. GRE
B KOW Y NOU TW INONHE
IN
IALITO GD AROUN IN00 2
5DEIXW
INALGH WITHI TSND AOT GFF O
VE
ENRY LNTIELY HEUG BRO IHTN
WY
LAESER LIKENTHNETA S
ALAIAR GZA W K,ST YOUWNE
YORAN
REU' GOIPNG UINST AGA
ESHISPACACTI GPAL,CA RHTIG?
ISWHAT SIGHA TTO YLNA TOU
SO?AL
>>EDGNSIAL TO ME B IRETTE
LECU E OURXETO ETIVEDI
NOW
AS IWHAT W DOING.
ISO KCKEDNON OAN MASDATE W
R ETIXECUVETRDITO A THE
TIME
DI SAIT I LOKEOOD T HAVE A
CO
SE
?ND
T WIANTLO TEL YOU WHAT M
GWORKIN
T JEUST ABOKEALDHEUT
SE. CAS
D T TIOL THEHIS MIGHT BE A
UGH
ROGOINND UERER S AGFT
REAL
LY POWERLFUPLE PEO HASE H
A
LEGALRS A AENALNDOU WLD
ENRETH.
ID HERHETO SRY T IOLD
HE
BOR AUTHE TNDOMEN W A SHE
TI
UL SMAAIOR GOD F IT.
A
>>HAT WTNT POI01, 27?
>> YES.
>>ROUAS BEND A GHRNGOI T
NT
MO AHSNDTH MON R OSFDIEANG
DOCUMEINSNT TRY TGOUR FIG HEOW
DTO FINANHE TSE J DEOES,
TTIMEROR
GEGRC SOU F, TESHE
RCW ENLAFOENTEM CEFHI.
TO T TORY TPE SAKO. YOU
STHAT MFSONTH OSK WOR IT THA
GH?
RASYE TOWGCKIN DOMHEN T WN
WATHE T MOSNSIM TE-COINUMG
AN
G TDRYINO GETHEM T TO
TALK
L YE A MSK AOUST QUE
IO
IN THE BOOKOU YVE WEA INSO
GME IEAOUND F R
IN ASTINREGNDUR SISPRINGLLTE
UR STOWNRYF OOU YR FILAMY
UR
YO KIDSEEC BOM SOS ALMTDECON
TERSARCHAC
YOALKOLS T YOUBO AUT ORWN
UP
NG.INBRGI
YOUWEREIOUSON CSCF O THET FAC
UD DIYO THINK IAN CE O ONEF
GIRESTHE?LS
O I>> NIDN' D
I NOTAS W CONFUSSCIO O ITN WHE
S TRTEDHEJE PROCT ATLL. A
I O
UTA HEIL S
IN AIEWIRVNGEN WOM.RTES
ICIALPELYEDERVINTEW
A
UPHE OIROM MS.
TOTHE STESRI THAOMHE TIR M
S
TOLDAYEM RDEINDE M OYF M OWN
MOTH SND A THE SUGTRGLE
HE
HAD SSINEGL
OM M.QU
ANKLE ITFR IY HADIGHT E IT
HTOUG GWIRONG U
P.
I PAD HTUT I OUT MYF O HEAD.IT
T S WASOR L OFIKE A
RE
INCKONGF O MY OWN WUTITHO
NN PALLYLAINGN OT I THA
WA
Y.
USI JTRT STAINHIED TNK ABOGUT
WOM
AE WSHASAI WARESSTR PTIMET-ANDW
OT WASD N WOME H ALEHO LOT.
EWE WERYAT LCHKE KSID.
D, IAS SAI DOL SELYNEAWDN O ME
D
IOT A L INN WOM CMO
HIT
THESEM
BUT D I NOTIDO D S THE FORRYTO
TT
RSOEAN.
JINTUS K OF HNEAPPEDT THA
WA
Y.
>>OUW, KNOOM SE OFHE TT BES
URAVSLIST HNDREE TMEOUS
ASCO
MP T ASIONND AHERERE
SCTVIIMN
ANYOU WEL TOT T S THELRYTO AND
OTO
PLR PHEEOND CANE USTANERD
WH
W THEATYOUT TENHR
GHAT
THY R CEAMOU THRGH.
TAHRS U THEGH,OU TEP RTINGOR
T'ERETH I T HARSDIN EOXPLA
N-
NO JALISOUTSEUD AIENC
DO H KTNOW MOWANY TUSHOANDSN'
ESOF PAG OUMF DOCTSEN YOU READ
TTRYING P TORACKPLEOEOW DN.
I ONENO KW OF H THES IOIERNE
NTH
RY I SETO TSHERARI LIB.AN
>> CAMONI I,TI SLLL FEELI
DIABRARNSO NOTET G L A OOTF
S
THER AREEY VTA IMPYOR TONTWH
WEATO. D
OTHELER RTHEA IEROI HNES MY
ERTNEPARHOLYMI, W
AS W MY
OGRAVIPH AERND PHETOHOGRAPR.
HSWA WITME M FRO-GHE T GET
O
ANAS W AEAL ROR ITANT
I,S
TANTMP IOREARO T HHE T
STOR
WEHEROG TETHE T
DOARIEMECUNTS ASEL WLS AO T
HEETO
HED REA TTO SRY
ADESH M WHEE R
RENANSDIMEIOL.
OELOULD C T THEL
TORYS
ETALLYRE BRTE TNHA THETH
OSANDOUSEN DOCFUMRIESTA
TH
DIDATT THA.
I GOINGO T GET TOHA T INT
ERE ITHNTEW PVIROSSCE BUT T
HA
S THERE P ARENTOI WHE YOU
SUDD FLYELTUT ORAGE?
>>
Y MRE PTT FUCROMHE T
INGGIBENN.I
AS WGEUT ORA FRO TMHEY VER
GINN
BE COUGIN I NLDOT
TADEUNRSOMOWND H SE LEONEIK
OUATA
WI
TH IT.
TH
HASAT I W MADT MEOE DT I.
LI I
KE IT U COLVENSDHARIT
D THAO SVEOL
.
T DONI'TNKHI AHE TSWERNS I
ALRELYNOWNO SET I SUT O TO
SOLVYSHI TS MRYTE.
OU YNEW K INK THI Y HADOUO T
GEYAN O THEFSE YOUOMENNG W
ATM
E OIT LTLN TERLD OECORHE RD
TOIR TLHERY STO.
N Y
CAOU UAK TESK? BAC
ASAT TH W.ST CRYAL
>>AKOUAN Y TE USHR TOUGH HOW
U F TOUNDHEPL CIRSTOUE OF
NDNWOME AHA WT H YOUOAD T DO
ETTO
GHEM THE TIR IRU TST
THINK?
TEON OF MHEOSTLTIFFI DCU
THRN A JGSOUASISTAL HOO T D
ISAK SPE TO WEOPL PEAVHO HELO
ET SSTOMNG.HI
:
.I HAD  IITVENCNSTITI
I EW ISTHNGAS G WOI
ANSSUE ERGOI WAE S
BEKIASIG THENG LEV HADHT N ER
ABEFOT RE UT TBOHERST WO
.I OF METH R
ANOMKNI EW SM OFE  THHAD
EVABOBLY N TEROLD ODANYB
THISNE HADAPPE.D
I D  YE ERVERYNGOU AN
WAD NCCOERNEWAI S G TOGO
APS PERMATITRREAUEM .D ZETH
SO IWITHOKSPE E EO PPLWHO
THESDID  OF KIE NDINTE
LIVIR FOA  NGTOE  S GETOM
T SIINGH  HINTOOWTO
IT.HANE
OFNG T THEHILUCOS I NCDED
S AT DII D  NDN'TEETO
EMRCE FOTH AO TA TLK UT TBOHE
USE.AB
ALPHYSE IBUSE A .
AS M WORT PORTIMANTHAT
TEOKHEM  TLOYOU ,N'DO
TTOT K ALABOU
NOERTHE'S N UE QSTIO TH
PPHAENE.
VEEISTN NE HDER NIEDE D DI
TANY OFS H
THE WATAS THITH OER.NG
ENIEEREV DITD
COMPNC OE HAT EDAR W HED
ALIN STOTEGEL A G B.
T DI JHEUSHINK'TDN TE  HD
NGYTANHING WRO
SO N WHEREAS AEVER ONESQUTI
ISNEAPAD HPED.
I D 'T NDNEE TR THFOEMO
TELLT E AB MOU.E RATHPE
I ST NEMDED EETH O TA TLK
ABT WHATT  I TD DOHANEO
THEM TND H AOW Y WEHERE
TRHED BYTE TL RIMI CNA
. JUSTISTSYEM
>>HRE AKUS T GHOU THERSFIT
WIRVTEIEW  THANEMILY
LATTH WASE IKURAND YOWN O
INELGS.
NE THE T O DIDNGHI II ,
D TETAHIS NGKI TBE ULWOD
ANYLIKE OTORY,R HEST
KN D TK ONHEANOOR D  TELL
TH YRSE PEONTOANOU WT   TALK
OUM  THEABT IT.
I DWHENT ON TIDHAOFE  THE
THN'S MEFAERS ANERSW EDTHE
T ANDOR IH UGHTHO OMY
'TIS ITHSNO OING G TRK W
CAT I CAE N' LL HTEER
.W OMIGHT NOEVT EN K
SOI HED DIANOTBESTR ORY REFO
HETHAT WTE IRE WROS  ATHE
F CTVIIM OA L VYNA SEA
ERS HIFATH ER LEA TT
PLAINIT I  WNGHA TO NTWAED
DO AND THERE THFAALL ID D C M
AN INTT GOAN WITVIEREWH
.M
SOTE W IRO ET60 LAL TTERSO L
MEE THWOTHNAT TTH AT ATI IME
KETRD ACWND DO .
ININCLUD WWHATG  I TED ANTO
INDO, I  CUDEDCL A PLE OUOF
CLT S ABIPOUW HOEEAS SD
ETD IETO G  AOFSEX
W NE LRASTTIONN EROWED I
YO O  SHE'SO YITRNG T
NYT OUOF A F KIND O
RIRESTTHIOCTNS PL WATERE EDAC
ONFTERIM H A  GOTHEF
UT O O
IOTE WRESE L ALTHS
D ANI T ONGOMAE N  ME LLCAE
.
OVELLECH LIV WHOE, L E
TSHVOF NE ASLE .
E SHD ESCONFSE L HTHATERAWYE
OTERLD H NLL TO  MAND E
WYERERTOLD HTAOT T NO
TOE AND STI JUALAD A H T
TH ON ERPHTHE D ONI
ERTOLD HWAHAT  WI DOED TNTO
ANIDSHD E SAOMKA OY, CANE D
D ILEMY AN KDII DN'T W NOWHEN
TOSWEET OOR F L  TTORAVE
TESEESE SHETWHHER WAS
IN GO TOROTH IH WIUGTHT
USE BECAW SH KWENESOMEHAE D
IVINMISG. G
AND HEATWE S T
WERVINTEIER DHEADITFOR  H TO
LE ABET E THAST RES HOUR.
J WD ITASTRUST EMELY
NAOTIOL .
D ILY EMANI ALRENK I TLYHI
DNDIY  REA'TLLNDDERSUNTAHE  T
HSDEPTTRF TH OE T MA TAUHAE SH
D OTHEWOR MEN HAD  GONE
H.THROUG
LYSHE ONEN WT PSTO E INTE ONE
Y TIME BE TY ANWAUST ITD  J
THATWAS   OME .TI
EALLIT RST ALY MODED
FE.R HELI
TO AND HE TEL HARER
L FUSAT OOF P TOWER
HE OFS
D UPUCTOHET  TONHAD ANY EMIL
DIRS COUE D A ILBRB T LIANJO
IOFT  D TINHERYENOCUMTA  BUT
LYU YOONMA S GETO ESINNY MUT
CUTHE DOANNTARMEY SO D
INMANY A ES ICHN ORY ST
THSO IN  WBOOKE  I ABLASE TO
T ABOLKUTOLHAE
RVIETEW WIAND OF EACTHH
THESMEWON ,LLEITHR FU
'SRE BES CAUSIT
IM UANRTT TOD ERNDSTANTHAT
YEIRLSSEHE G ON MEYBUT
WERTHEYLY REE ALED MISLAND
WERTHEYLY REE AL--
D W>>HY G YON'TOU TO TOHE
F ILDETA O M TWHATHE
WAS SA
T DOI N'AS TWANTO  SUME
ANDEY YBODUNWHNDRSTAS
G,ENHAPPIN I HOWS M IS TTHHE
LLBASICA WORKY EDHOAND IT W
T 'T JSNUSJESTREY FFEPN, EI
E E WAERS WH
INRETRUCASTUD  AM HID AN
ANMANY M WPEY OPLEE ERARAW
OF WINWAT S GO G.
SCYON U DET BERI THAFUS
AS AATCTE LLUAY TH
METHOGOLY ?
AY EEF JFR HADTEPSIN
YSTEECE OSND HARM OU
PELEOP THPE HATELM.D HI
AAS GUEAATY TH R
DIVE'T EN TIN S E HIOW
CEOESHLA
OMADHE H S DY EBODTOO
NGYTEVERHIIM FOR.
SO TEOPLSEHE PTHE ATE  WER
F RT OHILIFE THFOR
SYHE THAEMT AD  HT BUIL WERE
INVOON EEDVERYHEFRE OM T
ORL NTWHO WEDOO  TTHE
TO HEN CHEF IHEE THKITC
WHO  DENATHEM SS CK THETO
WORSE. COFOU
HAD OERTH WOMEUNYOG
HISNGRAED LE THESCDUTHO E
EKHOUSO R EEPEWHUPNECLEAD
TEHESE T DIDHETSID INCEN
D TH LOE PITSFLWHO EW E TH
TS ERWHE  P HADHE 2
VATERI
ERE DRTHIV DHE H, ADVERSRI
ICTHAT PHED KEUP T
SO W WITAS ATELEHO SYS
AROU EOM HIOF PE PL
.LRELY AIAND DEHES EDLP TH
BOOKTHN E OU Y BE SCDERI
T RSHOW SES E OMCAE FITH
TH G ETINWIMESO
A YOUNGI MIT BE
HE MY,WA SHTIG N
SS SSTDIRERE EWOMHE
NEEDSHE HES LP.
'S IT LMOSASD U F YOHAA
D WOUNDER IMALAN ODON'I T
BU THAANT T UTOPLEPE O
OKG GIR THFOE S RL AOF
E  HIP DALESCRONTI ATTH
THT E EY'ROUING
OME >> SIGN. DBYES
HED HACO UL THE HVEADOS MT
ISTISOPHEXPETECAD E NS
TUTEOSPRTI MONTHS ATLD  CEYOU
T THY BUBUOT W'SAT NU T HAYO
NTWAED
D AN WTEITEDSCAR LTLE S GIR
.
ATHEHAAS WT ANTE WAND D
T IDHE DN' EVENNT O OR NE
G  HE O,WA A EDLVREVO
DO AF TH OEM LLTITHE
PAT WTHASIST OFAR H NESCK
.S
I  LIKSOE ID, SATHOS TENHE M
INSIS OUPAF THRTISAL HL
F  OS WHENLSSEHE GIR
COUR SEMEBECA AREDSCHEY ND A T
'T WDIDNT AN DO TO ITAID HE S
T WODON'OUT Y RRAB, ITU YO
T HADON'DO I TVEO T  JT,US
FYOING URNDDSRIEN AL  I'L
TTHPAY EMAMAMHE SE  OOUNTF
.NEY
PL P HADEOIZCTE VIIM ED
T  DIDEYN'BENT TWAO
AIMIZCTEDUTMORENY BHEY  T
MED TEDHE WEY FONORR HA
ON .AS
EYAND THULUST  JWO GBRIND G,O
TITO PARRI ANDES B  THENGIR
S FRIENDRINGOR N EOTVEN
TPEOPLE TT HAWEREREHE
IEFRNDS
PEOPULHE TY WOD ETME,
NTANQUCEANS DN ATTH'S I
LLTHE MA .
THOR AT  WGYE M OR
HAD  HSOE WHOLA LEE GIF ON O
TECRUIR
METHE E  SN INOMHES,CASE T
MEOUSUWHO RR F HNDEDIM
TH MOSTSTBE
ANTIPOLICIS, SIBUN NESS
E RPORCOATADERLES O WHRE WE
E PA WF TH OIS SLD ORIN
WAESD I ANGUATS THOF ON'SE
THEAR UNE CLIES STMYE.
S THERE'TO MSOUCH UGO  GTHROH
REHE.
ANO WAI NT TTRRTSO OF D Y
TLE  L AIT T BIOF
BUTLONOGYF THNE O OE
T OF MGSOSUND S  UFOE
TORYVERELAE BON  ITH OK
2 E  EURXPF THONTI O
S NDINGI V THEIRS LAN ISN
.
S  AU TAYOLKT UT WBOHA
GOG  AHEON TREOWND H THAT
F PARTS  OLDIS WTHOR OF
FFN EPSTY EID HIANS
S FR?
MESO IALS OD OTHF DEINING NT
S ELF MSTOAL OCCIOFFI
TH HROU TGHPHPYANILTHRO
OR DORIOATNS G UI BLDIN
INSOMETHGAT'S, THLMOS
EE0 36DEGRS E STSYEM HEACRTED
>>ULDNE HCOE PI H'TAVA
PLATTBEER CETO F HISTHURER
ATEIMCRES ISLTHN ISD ANTH
GHOUT OFCOF THAS T OF
OM. THAS
LYE THONOU WAY CETAN G  TO
IT LIY IS BHER ERCOPT O
BO.AT
ANYOITKNOWU , A  ALS'SO
PLACE WHEROPPE.  ON LEST
THOMASE AROOETTYPR PR.
AND POTHE CIANLIS KNYOU , OW
RAHE INGIMATTIED HH LFSE WIT
THESMEGOE VERNICIA ONTFF LS
CIANLIPOTIS
THTHE  OFEF OVERENTH GR NO
NT T WOO RKEPSTFOR R
NY YMRSEA
LIS YE0 AR
END ANTH AT DHEONED NSTE
THS SANDE MAND,HU
SATHOUDOS OFND  ARS LLTOILD BU
SCEROLS HOTE .
ILT BUE THRST FIMUOLC SCSIHOS
, SOAM PERROGRS.
STYOU JU AM NE ITI, AS W
HAHIYTNG THET  ULCO
Y S HIMONAT.
SOY TAVIB, ESE TH
, MECA TKN A HOWIMDYMES SOBO
OWHSOMEATFABEF A NE CTOR
D  TTHEYD URNETHS HEEIR AD
HEE THOTR WAWHS E EN HWA
NGINBRGIAL IN L THS GIESE RL
F WOUHELDTH INTLYO T AIRPE OR
ONTE PRIISVA A PNDHEN  T
IARA HAO NG N IN AEA AR
WASAT COSTILL  LEMPTELY
E VISIBL TNEEVERYO .
MBD ANDISE TK ARWITH  GHEIRLS
AN WOUTHD EYALLY ULDSUN
COPTHEA LIT WA TERHA KES PT
THEYANE D OU WLD BE
SLHETO T IAND.
O O>>NEINE F THTHOUGS Y REWE
ILFOINLOOKG FEMAR A NIST
FESN LU OTH BGHE LITSUT
HOALSO WOUW  FLEAR
EEU'VEYO BLEN  T
HOT OFLO T S'SWHO , HE
TH WI, SMELAHONDHAURITECY S
D BLOCKEHRTHOU ?GH
SE B>>ECAUNANF UORTUN LYTE WHE
TEI STARTHDOD ING  ISISTHAS W
ERR TEMY SS IERAN WAAND I
TRYIO  TGET ATINFORM
ATTH RSAND FID A I T DI BLPUIC
CORDREEST RES QU
GET DII D F ITMESO OT UT B I
BELD CRE IOU  GETANA AND
UT AMOREBO IT HEES A WASRR
ANE OUOF CRSWA ITHENT  S AN
NARIEN CMIIGVEL INSTN ATIO
'TWAD I SNO NG GOI TGET
YTHI
M I'EELD ITO NOPTO SD COMY
GHLIA SELE CTTLO
'S ITGRKING TTDAOR IID.A
THBETT IISS .ER
?ATHHO, W'
T BETWAY  AERNY.
K  L YOUOOME TGOODO .
SECAI N U E YO
CAHAT  TBEISE OFUS HEATH D
SS TH IAT NETHIOMNG OT
ALSEN  OR EDCAETYONEAN G
D?AD
ON>> I D T THI'TNKY'REHE
IVG TOIN GTHUS AE NYG ONIN
.H
E THWONHE'S GT NOE W BU
CAS  IOPSTILL .EN
AND LLREEOTICAS I Y GUES
THER L SISTILLNG AOOT
OTHEDEOPPELE ENDECIS EV
ISLAGHXWELE INMAWAS WHL O
CTEDINDINNN  ICOO ONECTI T
FITRSEX AFERG CKINOP
OFON>> E NG T THEHIS, E
IOREDICTASATN TH W LIPECU
INANOOHE BKD I IOMENT
EA.IER
ASAT W YOURG HINK TIN AS A
ERREPORT
LO OFS TIMENAADITTRIO
E STS LID  BEHGOIN
CU N, YAIOUT N'T DOGEOF AN
E THTHUPSD , DOWNS
CHLEES NG SINOF A
AT S WATHDECITHE  YSIOU
ED TWANTO R WAKEMA O
, YOITEDOR URDITOOKBO ER
I ER EARIDLIREND T AHE 'SENAS
L NDERWOFUHEENESSC T.
Y WHDOYODID U T? THA
ORED MY IT W, IT
PA EY IALLMYR DITOGHTHOU
ATY S STHIORD I T THOUGH
UAIT ACTIDY, ILL DT NO WANT T
T DO THAY ITIAINLL.
NTN'DOT WABE I TN ISTH
Y.OR
THAND WA AENS I G WOS RKIN
METHRO WISAS AE TID UNTH
OFTRUMP ANTHE ALD L GSTH
E ATTH HWAING PUS TTAT T OUTH
WERE .TRUE
THLIURE JONAG BESTS IN
D INPAT E TASHEF NEMYTHE
OP .
KNYOAND U OW, TEAFTHE R
SE ES RRIANON BOF TE HE IG
S RPRISUSETOHOE WA MS MUCHW
FAUIMAN IL QLY FTERANK G IOT
STURJONALIGENES VER FAT N
K ANILUT JOFA T LOT  TH
YOFRNOU TES E  POMEOPLYISANG
FIS IS TY,HIHA WT
JOS SMLI
ANWHY  IISS 'SIT
.NT POIMR
AND RECCIT OUR
STNAJOURLI AENS AR'T
D  GVERYOONGELAT TLI
DO WWHATE  WEHOAND W
AB T I.
.CIT DO
ANNKDO TI HI T TH AISME TI
ISTO HRYOR'S IITMPNT TA
TLAWE EXPOP TO INPE
OF  WECDO BSE AUE BECAUS
ALGSE THTHIN AVTHAT H
HAPPNK IED THI GOA
MEAOFMERI  HCBE
.S IST FUSTL OFSTURJONALI
SOOUGHI THE I MAT YB
Y HE  THEMWHATO  ISO T
TARSND
TH'T A IISSNRT EFN FO TO
C, KNOWTOTH AOVERNYING .UP
ES IS IAN T FFORTOHENDFI T
UTINI AND TH WATK TH'S
MOSSTNAJOURLI .S DO
TSOAND  IUGHTHO G M GOI'IN TO
TTT A PULIF  BITLE O IS ATHND
ETHCAE USITTHINI K
PAMPIT, 'S INT FORORUR O
Y COUNTRCID ANESPEENLYAL GIV
CTTHE FAWSHA TT NEPEPARSL
APAWSPERS OLLVER ISTH
E TRUNY ARSTJU G ANARFEIN
AC THION D'T NKTHE
HALIZREES OWDEING STVAAT
R O  TOUDEY CRMOACAT WTH
ARMALLNGSI S NEW PEPARS
OVALER T HEUNCO.TRY
HREI ERE AGE.
WYOAND URAICEORK RTS SHNLY OW
ERE ENAN YOUCE CAKE. M
E THT'GS TINHA REALS LY
CACOTE ITO GD ET O, TNTHE
ONRVERPESIICF JU OSTIS IE
RFK INA PET ECBETITLE E
ET YCEOU G HIINTO TANS D
L SEU E ALAPTHAT HNEPED AND
PROIT'SCOMPBLBAY AND ENETT
AINEEXPL TD ERMSE
STSYEME PLD ANTHYOU ERAYS
D HAKT SOABOUTHE  OMEF
TOCEACSSININXP ELATHG E
TFOEFRTT OTO PREC
ANEIEPSTN  TE D ONOFNGHE TS
EN HWEAVD AL'T TKE T ABOUIS
E FECITYS F  OHIS RNATTOEY
AFGOING VIR THTEE IMS C.
WHIS H PAAPENING LLWHOU  Y
. ABOADUT I
A AU YOTALKBIIT LTLE T
ABNDTHT AT AATHA WT THID D
E TO SOM Y TOFHESEENNGOU WOM
ITIN ADDHEN IOTO TNADD AITIOL
?TRAUMA
>>INE IMT AG 14 U'YORE
S OLYEARYOU AND D D DI
SORRIBG INHO. L
OFYTH VER AOUREMED ASY HA
LICEE THPOOUT IN FD OUABT
HEY IT.TND TMECO AOCK Y HEKN
YOUR ORDO  TD WAANNT
ND YOUTO A E  COUOFRS
IN EXPTOLA PA YOUTOR NTS RE
WHTHE Y RELICEPO A TALKI TNG
D I NFESCOS THNT TWEO
USYS GUHO
US T I GHWAIMVINGGI H
MAE ANAGD 'SHEREHAT  W
HA
ENTH ATTEAFR TH, AP HPENSTH
HINEXT TNO YNGOU KVEYOW U HA
THA MAN ON YATOU D E'TVEN
KNOW  EJUSTLLHEITR FOINOWG
U  ORCOMI INGNTO GEL E THBA
P WHEYOU  HREE NDRKWO A
NG ICOMIYOANN D UR  SSBOES
NGANSTDINDRE THE AN 'S HE A
ALFIOFCI MKI LOONGAN HEAND
YS NWEALTOEED  T  YK TOOU
D ANITRNTU'ST S OUIT
PRATE INVE WIGATSTOR
R FOFFJEEIY EPRESTEYAND N TH
NT STOWI DOWITN ND YOUTH A
EYTELLK OU L YO IF Y, OU
LLBASICAU  IF Y,YOH RK WWOIT
US  BWILLNDFINEE  A
EN DOITWORK WUS H TH
YOOI NREOT G  TNGO BENEFI
ANAMYOD UR FT Y ILMIGH
YNEFI FORERR OUFATH  IS
EDLL.
ERE'D ANTHLIGHHES ADHIS  ITSN
.ORREARMIR
IM OUN R H ROA TFFHD .
WASTHISY HAEA RLLG ENPPIN
HESETHWI TTI VMS.
FATHAND E PRHACT TT S UTOSECOR
WA IKNEWT INPPS HAENG D AN
IDEYTH DNYDON'T  AG THIN TO
OPT IST  JUN', I DO
T OW WKNHAE THARWORDS  FOR E IT
.
STWAS I JUKEO SH SOCD
>>F AIDNY OOSE PELE
BEHAD TO HENELD ?CC AOUNT
L SEVERAIRFTLE THETEOB JS AF
CASTE ORY  BUT OMEUTTH IE
AROU GSOO HING NNDOT
ANYS ENTO
HE T LY PONPLEOE REAL  WLYHO
S HI PVEAIIN TICPRE
.HOLG ARTHE INNWOE ME
TIMS VHEICO  T, KNYOU OW
HEENEV T ORECPROSUTS D AN
PRORECUTS THATDVAT AOC
FO THEM, SE LETHAD
ECUTOSORFEAD RAL DE
OROSECPRUTENRE W AOM
T KNYOU CA, OWTHE  S SEWENT
E BEWHCAR E USTHEISSBOES
EDHAO PPENTHO  TALL MEE N
WHATSECUD D ANE  HDI SAD ID
CTIME ESVICREDARS ELEIB
THTUTEOSPRTIS.
ITBIG T N'A ALDE.
THLLREE WE AXCSE THE E USES
THDEE  WERMA.
LOUK ABT VED INAN E
STS THERY E'N ALEDOR IT
E SOMEO TS D  BEHISIN
CUN .AI
AC INTURERTHONS TIWI SEY CA
TD ANYOURABUGHOHTS T OUR HE
'TERE PIDY TTCANDI , DNDI
LKENDERNY A UT TAE AGBU
Y FRCAT SEK ANE
ONSHLARETI HAD YIPOU W
OREATTH EED HER LP
HI ANDERNDEDHOLEHE T W
RTH D ANF.
YO, KNU OWSMNAJOURLI CAN
VSSY MEY.
D  WALPECILYYOHEN U HAVE
TW PSTROO NGERPLE,EO VY
ASTROADNGUI I'MND Q TE
CA M ABOIDUT WELF YSASL .EL
Y I MAERHASOL TO DN EA
F  MYSTHEL
ANTLWAY ASS , I WA
EDT ONORE POINT.
NG BT ECASSEAU I WT N'
VE IOO GD AT .
D ANWAS TOH UG SOMTO
RES ANRTPOEI D ET IREGR.T
IS T ISOT S HIMIDYNA
ET SYOUROM IMESAT
.OSPURPES
D D S SEY'ANR  EDIMYTOR FO
ALNT THEST E E TIIRM
VEARS YEI' TEEN  BAT HE HERAL
.
WEOSRET WAYSAL
AGSAME PINWIE TH KOFD
STORE THS AT WE INTHK AR
ANIMPORTT TIT BUSOME
Y WATHATWAI  A TNTO GOUTBO
SN I'TETH THIY WAHE
SHOUABOU GLDO
I IDSA PRETI'M BBOR STYTU
D STROHEAD SO  ANGND HISE
SOS MESO WASE H.
HOWAI S  NESTAB THOUT AT
T DOD I N', KNOW TINNDHE E
IN MDGKNOWACLESANTS MEI
R R, VEOUWE WNE HAVLDE
E ME SO TOFES STOHERI
HAN'AT DTHID.HAPPT EN
T ESICHANAT TNGHE L
S CLASTHS WATHE  MG INTHAT
OUIESTORORSOS  IMPNTTA AND
OW, U YOKN, WEMEI ANUS JT
D ALVECORES BAL SEBECA
. USWE
TO  HWEADCOETHE TMEOG
FOR ENE D KE OE THSA
STY O.
WLEU E YOABE SH TO AR
EAURYO FRS  DWHAND AT E ID HDO
HE ETOITR THAGASSUE R EM O
OULP Y ,SED YODIU
ISYN INSE TCARA
PPENHAED W THEORRECK A KASNO
T DO OR
>> MEHAI D SOHIEI WRD TS NG
ONPHAEN WISTHH E PR
STTHATIE INEAV HE DO
ANMBI D REME ERCALLSEY G INCA
TIMEONE ER A SHAD ONMEE
SHOWAT M UEDP TMENAPY AR
LE OMIE DDTHE F .
PRETWAI S CATYRED HE ENWH T
ON PRIS RISEETHE , N STEPEI
I DRISEES'TON OWKN.
R EAERATEV RSON
EL'TDIDN RUN MEASEE TIL WELL
THTEAFR  RRIE SEESNDAN A I
NTEPS DE IIT .O
RDIDNI 'TVELLY EAHAN  REA ASO
TOIMK TOAL HHABOUT A T.T
HOWE AITR  WASALOT L AT L
WAS THERFFENT
E SHLOWAS A AYMOT RE PG IN
IOATTENTT TON  WHAG S WAGOIN
I LE BLIA TTE  MITOR
Y.ORT OUTH
T ENITWFFER
IES ALONITAY SATTH W
WH GOA ODE BULABANC
LIKD ULBEE YOARU CR
ULD Y WHWO TU YODOHAT
NTESGO ILECOO A UP OF OSTHE
ECT ABTES OUY EMILD ANI
THNGROER GWI  THE
URRNITE  OROIN FNTTHE F
L ROTEONDDOOR AINE FA MLL
LE E BEI'NGTHINM KI
EVER.EMIL, Y
LID, I SKEAI'TT WA ISN
S NEWE KT THATW  I
RE LYRISES OUATTHOW N
S EISTN WAGOE G INTO B
ARR STREED ONGATTH CO SSRE HAD
FOASKED R JUTHE ICSTE
RTPAMENTSTINVEN ATIGIO
'S WTHATIRD N HEWE INTHGS
HAPPTEARDINENG
PEHOWILEOP S UNGP VAN,
PAILY'N  IEMS USE HO
OUCK C THELO
SOPPELEP NGHOWI UIDOUTSE MY
ARAPICT TMENWH A NH ISOTN
SYLACE.
A'S NITOTEOLACE P PULE PLWO
WNG BKIY .
IPEOPLEEVTHE N ELOR, A
FIVE BELLYIEHA TT E THER
EOWERE P WE PLTHATE ER
I. IGSTATIND ILEMY AN
SETO BHAECSEAU THE CA
D ANSTJU GSON  T HO
OM TN EIFR HEBEG
THE TEAFR  RISEESWAID AFS RA
ATING S WAGOE TO B
D ARG.
W  KJUSTNOAU BTHATECSE
APEOPROHIUND M E LDTO M
INS WAGOE G TOCHD ARGE
OU ERULAINXP B C
N'NGSTRIEEN ROLES  IUR YO
?
EV WH>>ENE I HERAV LOT A OF
Y ANXIETALWAHI TURYSN ON M
STAND JUTOIS LTEN IM H.
D ANAYLOA NG D RI WTING,
OUROWKN, I  UEWP AS Y
MENTEARLNEIOD
ELPHILPHADANIAD SP
S MMSUER HOASR.
HE A STOREAGRT R ELYTLE
'SNTRILL I AND K THIN
HIJUIESTORS D ELST HPE MAKE
H, EDFO COMRTOMIN ME  SE
Y.
LLSPEC EIA WWHENY  I AS
A OKTHE G BO ATE
LOF  DAYNG OI ITINWRG ULD WO
ON RNS SERIOUD DIRAO AN
LAJUST PY M E THRE EN
S IDNIT TO  PHEOINT KMY
.EWELLIK LE ROR G INTHEIESEY
DO WOM M,  TO HAE VE
EN TLISTE SPBRO UCEEN NGRIST
.GND ON AIKIGTHF IN
KINDWAT S F  OPATHE  ORTF
IC OFABRIFE MYF  LWH
S Y STORWAUN
PEAILE SD NGHAVI STORY.
IS, THISTHS  IALLY
ALULD CORE GETLY SEDEPRES
IN IIS ATHND THINK AS IT W
THSOME HTHING ATD ELPE MKEEPE
I OKINDF .
>>ARIST A DANSTK ORY D
I'BACK G HETO TS.AR DKNES
E ONHE OFEND K HE T BOO
HEAPTECH IRSS FFREJE
EPNOT DIN D LLKIMSELHI.F
SOSTATS T'A ENEMT SO
PLU YOEXTAANAIN D
UGTHRO TTHH EIERCEHE PSS
USG  HTHATORINEADLE T  THA
APL FINACHE TITER TL
HA'STHAT WLIU T YOBEEVE?
THAS T K.I
EDI USUSHIS  TCAE THATAS  W
L  OF RTA  G THINATS WA
NDCISO A MALEDIA
EVHEYWRE.
TUUR O CULUR YREOU T D NEON
WAS  INDT AND ERTHE E TH
E ONGRI ASE ASOME,
T OFFLA OA FFREJE
EPFREY JN,EF EPSTEI
IT COT MMICSU
ITISE ECAMT NTMA NDRA A I
OKD DILO TH AT IS.
OULEPEOP WS LWLD AAY
AS IWHEN WNG DOI OFLOA T
COLKEGE LLTAS AT TS HIME, TI
CNALIURSMNDSSESLA EOPL PE
MED ASULK
I LY ALHIDN'TDI TS  HE NKWA
E CAPABLTT COFOMMISUICINID
BY HLFSE.
HECOULD AV HEUL, COE ITD  HAV
BEEND SS AISTEWEICSUIDE ONST
RKYES
INK I THWANT WIFE INK O  TTH
ANTEHE WND ITOD  E, IT
ONMEE E  HMUSTAVI EDHELP,
STJU THN'DOT  WINK AS
PAE M D ANI'ONTHNOT E
HITHERLAWYS , THINK AT
FOHO PNSICATHASTLOGI TT WAS
ESTOP DOEVT BEN'LILEHE KE ILD
F HIMSEL
THSTE'S ERJUY OO M TANE STRANG
TTHINGSENT HAHAPPAD.HEED H
S E REBONEN OKBREN IS HI
CKNETOND A DOCL MIR CHAEDEBAN
ICFOE RENSGIAT PHOLO  STSAID
ELHE RARHAT INY  TF NDKI O
HAINNGG  HAVETHONESESRE B
BRUR N  IYONE C
MI IKEEPN HEORHEND T TY
THATHES  T DIDHI AWITH
DSETINCU, TTUPESG THE
THAT D  KHEIN OFEDPULL
MST AGAIF NSE THOKBOHE ,
T IT EDTO TOPHE  ABUNK
HEE LD HOUAVPUD TOHA
HIF E
GHRASALRELY WT N'OUEN
VEOUTYCI, EN RGHOOM ERTH
D AN HAVM E NEDO ISTH
THTHRO BKEN S.E REBONE
OW, U YOKNILETE THTOESRI
THATON TER WE HIS  OOPF NKBU
EVEWERESHIRHIN S HEN SOT  T
HAVEYOU GUARTW O DSTH
T EPASLE AL.WHTHE EETH
YOEO VHAVEID DIRESAPPD
U D ANYO  OFINDUTTHUYHEAT T G
ATE N AS ITHCEHIITLL WH M
TTAKINGJUT OUHAT
BEHOURS S RE TFOHI.PPENHAED
IT'S JUST, E VE DI'ONIME CR
ANRTINPOG D CIALESLY
ISFOEA DTHS R IMLOA NG T
S HIMYT UT G JUS TLLTES ME
WAS NOT JUCI AST SUI DEATTH
HE DELY  BHIMSF
HE W>> T WRO YAYOUT TTEHA
TEAPR ERIS CLLLYTAIN A
ESONS ESQUTI
A N ISRAINE UT IIDLA O
AYNTRE W
AE ERISY QUN INIRT ISN'
ERE NMDEHAISARK  T E T THUS
OEYTORN'SE FFICIN  NEW
HAISRK,  TTG ENHAPPIN?
>>IS YOREWK AOOKI LNGTHE T
TWONRRECCOTIRSOFFIS CEHAT  T
WERE ORETY DUALCKY STADRU
EAPLEA DEISO L THT R
HEREINGOE  AGAIT WH
TYTERHINGT HAEMSE
DYD ANNOBO 'SLKTAT G INABOU
ARTHAT PANT D ERTH
PASERATEJUDEPAICSTE  MERTNT
IGATVEINST THEN IOBY
TOR SPINECRAGEL OFHE T
E DESTJUICNT RTPAM
STIL IITS ING.ONL GO
I T KNDON' IT' WOWHYNG TAS K
THG  LON.
S HAOH TT'ENL STILOP.
ANF EVENTH CLIE RUNG OMES
ERATT WHEVLIT  THARUS NG II
WKNN'T OWHETHERHE T
WIDILE EVERL  BDE MA
IC .BL
LMOUM'S JP E O RE TTH
PRW.ENT IDNO
GHXWINLAE MAL L,EL WILU YO
HVECORING A TERRIAL ND WHAT
NGUDO WILHI TNKMIBEL  CO
T ? TOFHA
>> LAGHISELMAINE XW L IS
AKING GEPATH O OUTF E
FFY STEPNSDEEIN FE
T IN TE'SHA RES HID
VERYER-PHIGHOWRSAWED LYE
HAVE EIOPREVUSE IEXPERNC
E STJURTDEICE PA MEN
AN, KNYOU OW  ATHEYRE
DIBONGSEHE P TROTORSCU
TH WIALOFKINDL S RKAPER PWO
TIAND S THSTJU ANYG IN
HETHAT TNDCAY N KIW F  OTHRO
WAT THE, L AT'PIHONG I
D MESO KINOOPH AOF LE OL.
E GOEYTH'RTOIN INLY ITEVAB
E THARGU ATS PAE SHWA
GINA OATRIL  T, INHE
ALIGORINATL  DEATH
CKSTRU IER 2008THISS E WATH
NGSTRAF RTE SO OST ICODES
EAHETO T DHEERL WHE  S ,HI
SPCO-CONATORIRS E THERREWE
W WOMUREN HOEDHELPIM H
CH HTHIS SE ED GWEREENIV
S NIMUTY ALLWE ELAS WASL
U OMSOMEEOAMNNED P E PLTHAT
WEDOSTILL KNOWN' W THOHEY
WERE
AND R HEWYLAERS ARGUILSTL
H ONE WHEAS  THO
.EOP
WHR HEATTHMAILL  WRE IN
S TOMAREINEN E  BSE
DACOS SHSTA OWISN UP ITH
AGANAIN D ANAIN D  E ONOF
TAE THDEHEINILS  T  B
E WROTRETHE  EW AVIND
LLBASICAY D FOUNM HIGUF
UDGMORPO JT T ENBUTHNO EAL IC
D ES PSANFO THIINS NOTEOT
T IRET PORTSAT YS  MANY
EOF HISVEILMAS HA NIVAEDSH.
>> EY DTHSAY N'IDT Y YBANOD
ISSELPEARIS DAPST H, EDJU
. L
HISIT'SS DUMA EILHE NGRI T
ODPERIISN  WHETHS L  DEAWA
NEHEANAT VISD
K YSOOU NOW,ITGUESI S
SNEYIKE  LTH HAID HSAE
S MAJOA R L  OF SSAL
EM.LS
TIT WASS  EMAHEILTHRINGDU
OD HIWHEN TASDEALS  W
GOED ATTPE DISATAPED .
O >> SIN EINPSTEWH W'SILL
HEOUTERO A CAYE PLOF D
BEFOFOE  HWAS  D UNDEA
HSTIS NTH A WETORT
.IOLLN
THIDU K YOSAENTH IN E D
TTH BOOESS MBE NUERMAY
VETHEDHANG, HEAT T
CTSAMPS COEND  FTIONUNWAS
D EACRTEINI AND THIDU K YOSA
NDD EN W75OMLEE  HAVFID
AI AS D LEALGEANIMVICTS
F7  6N MILLION VE BHAEE
.TPAID O
SOENSE WHOOMTH, ARE
E E AWARAR OFT'OR WHATHE S
ERESS OCTE ?
>>REDOE N'T W LYAL KNOOUABT
ALOUT TH BW  I KUTNO
MEWYTHE F LAS WHERO
.ETHENESTED  E
THMEARE E WOF SON ME O
W TAY HAD TH SVEAI AT
EISTN ESSELLNTY
CKEDAFTRFIHE TM OUT OMTO SE
TTAMPSE IORNT BUMN T
AD FRRE AAITO  COME
D RWFOAR.
U MET OK ASO ALIONE KELAN
RSO  WITZWHHAD EDATTACK
E N MAUSAT ATHCC HIMED.
HYEARR S,HAD E EDSU. H
HE AD, I MEANAD HHEAD M
FEHER LI RE ALLYSEMIBLRAE.
GI D EVEN OTIN TR
HIS ENWH TS WAHAG, IENPPIN
GOLSAI A AND F LECOUP O
CAONPHE LLS  SFROMLEPEOME OP
O EW  DALANZ OWERSHIT
SATH WOHEAT TY R NEULD VE
HIANSAY YT WBONG AUT THHAT EY
KN TAU BECSE AY WEHEREAID FR
IM . H
D ATTHTH WHA'ST MEESN ,
THEYATTOE RNWHO S RE
.HME OSOF N E WOESMEID S
AT THE G NREEVERGONGOI TO
PUBL BHEAUSEEC T RE TY'OO
OAFRAIDHEWHATF  TEN  M WILL
EMPUT TH.HROU TGH
>>U REN HEYOOOK AAD BE TH
LISTN ALF  OMEY
ED IVOINLVASTOIG .
ANALS DEE NIE AR
MSD AREHE A SEEO LSIT
E ERMESO V
CEIDEVEN E  SFROMOM HEOF TSE
ANMEWON D  P TALSOHE ATTE
E THEREY DCET IDN'NE
FEEL OLIKEFFNE OS .
CH IO TOMU IN SES ENE T
REING RT.
>>YES.
WHOOK  TA UTE TOIL P
GE IOFT TOAUERTH BEC SL NOT AL
WAOF IT  INS  ONE
REERTHE WENTIF DFERE ,ERTHE
SRETATEVEINNSIGSTATIO,
NDESTL RAINVE AATIGIONS
THE RTI FBREPOCIVITH E
I
LA T
WERHE TRET OFA E LO
.NT FFDIER ECPIE
AT'SK INTHER NO ATHG THIN
PIECHEOTR HIS OFE  T ITHAT
T N ERGETH I THISOKBO
CAOUENE WH Y  AREDOA ING
EE PIECLIS  THIS THERE'
MACHNFORTI OU AND YON'T CA
IYS PWAUTT HIEVERYT IN NG
S STORE IE.
DELVEMOSO INTREO  OF ME
E UDTAE IL'TCOULI D CLIN
INNA OHERIGISTL ORY .
>>DO YOROU, L OU Y FEEKELI
U'WI DONREE OR THITHS  DO
D?YOU  TL WAILNTGABE O EN
NOYOGUESI S ARRE U'ST
E OKSTBOOR AT OT LEAS
TOUR .
SUREI'M Y ERY REU' VTED HAEXUS
.
ISEUSAN JT OU TE ITHRGH
M T BUI'DF MALSOIN OTHUL AT
OF TTHHE OERTAS HINGI
AB  HT ISOWSOE EOME PPL SAID
UST  MBENI T TO CEDOT HA
BU NTHATT 'S IOTT RKS.WO
WAG DOINLAE PATHRK
SHNG, TIWAS ING DO
TISHOOE  ANGT THRTFO
DALEUD APOIRRT.
RIS WACOVEHO ANGLL T SE
R HEINTHGS WTHN IS
EDHAPPEN  JUSD ANWE
UNFOY HAATUNELD
TRAIBRRLEN DYGE IDE.RFSUSI
YOU AND OWKN,  YOUWHEN
R R A R PSM, A PER ALLEPA
U ST T DON'  THAVEHE
OXULURYF G GOINNEONOFF  O
INTH
LYOBI PRABBIE  HAVA RET MO
UR LTHATUXTHANY TH OERS
E BUU OW, KNYO HREALU LY
TOIN IJOHE CONN  TE.EROVAG
>>UD TORHE A NCIEE IN
COYET,EX 20 ORS ARAGO O  S
LIVEULD WOHAATEEN  BWH
THD  CEYALLECHEDATTARK O  TWO
HIS ON TD AN THEHAVEOM RE FED
YSTTO DUT B E DATHES
ARE OMROS T PRABOU
H OFFIA FT  THEWHAT WEY R
ME'SS TIMEITDS H ALLAN  IN
SD WHHEE N 'S ITH DDMILE
UG AOF HANPOE IMRTT
S  TLIKEHINK TSO IHI T 'SIT I
KSSP VBOESOLUM AUT
NCISPERSTEE  WYOAND UR
HIURAND C YO ATTERMDEINN IO
O TH DI
KN W HOT FFICDIULAT ITHS
D THSPECRET UTHELLE  OF  O
.
UE'SRE A QOMIOSTN FRHE T
.NDICE
YOONUCTOHED LET  ICOUP OF
S M
BU SOM AATREHE OFE  T
ESTIMAINS ONREG,IN
MYOUT S IEABY
N YOSTEPEIER WOU NDABD
HAV YDOOUANE Y HOTHIN APENY
COMWILOUE T
IT TOO A LSED.
KON I D'T HIFNOW  IAVE MTI
R ATL TH .
K THI INHEOFONE  TNG THIS R FO
PLEXE IS DNDIDY ANY'TBO
THO ARWHE GUYSE  WHHEWEO RE T
CONVD TESEX OFER FE
S RLACSED NGOL MESTI GI
ANOU GHEETS L OFT  JAIIN
2009DYD ANNOBOG  P'SAYIN
IOATTENTN TOE'HE WRE H
FL NGYI HISD ANPLE AN O'WHS ON
ANHIS PLE WEMARKERSTN T' IS
OGGLNDMI-B ME G INT.
ANYDOESATCHDYBO W HE TSE
MAEY'RE URTHNOE T GEOETUTAND
RLS R OTHEGIFRNOOUOM Y K
EANEERN W YORINDRK A BG NGIN
R O EM TOUCOY UNT
S PEIT SAK WE TO MHEASN'
PNG AVINYEMS TER H
OUT GOT L . JOFAI
HE ED TURERNEG HISTO RAR UL
O  ANDFE NPAE WAONS NG YI
IOATTEY NTN
OTHAT'S T THINENGT HAOUSH
BE KED OOATHYIS W ER WEN'T
HETHEY CINCKG PLHIS  E ANWHEN
OHE GOT INOMST. TH ANDAS
NGASKIGIHO TSE OLS RLHOW
THEYE ER?
ONE T'HAS UMPEATTH JOUD T
ANHE BIND  TU SHK OOYOT
ERE  IOUFAN CT Y NG
OME  GORIRLSFROUBRGHT
OVASSE  NTOANOREW YK
S WHO'O,WH U N CAYOUT ATALKBO
S WHTHE O'WHO  TOFONANHE MSI
THSOE E ARALTH O ONEF E
S DETAILARVENOT E GI
EN HWHE S WAIVE A
T SISTASANNE ATTUSORY
HORIBESCS W ATMANHY N, TTAHE
FOD UNREHUNDOU ODSF TH
T NOOUTHUNNDSAS, H EDDRS OF
THS OFSAOUNDGRAPHO PTO
E 13 NMIUD15-Y14, , D
I  WHAKNT OW THT AT
CATEINDI.D
BUNETHE ANRKW YO MO  ASIONL
W  K, WENOE WRYOU ITT ABOU
OSOMEOPE F THPEENHOLE W WT
UDE INERCL GG BIINLLES .A
ELOTHER FITED ECOFALS CI.
PEWE ANNCDR.
ONND YOOW, KNLEE PETHOP
HIANPLE.
CLEWTOINN FLPLN  IHIS E,AN
ALPETHL ESE ERE LEOP W
HIST OUOFIF LE HIS EROV T
PERTIMEEN HD IOWHE WAS
LVEDINVOTHISIT WH EX S
FICKTRAFERG INOPN ATIO.
E OMS,CTIM SM  TE OFHE
VESOEDCCUS, EMF ME OTH
VEHEUSEDCC TBE O MENF ING
EDINVOLV
ISIMS E ATTH OESN D'T
ALREAN HAVLYE SEWITNY ES
EN A'RE OUINRO OME ITH  WTH
INMAN DOTHISG  TH, E'S ER
REDYBO THE BO CTOORROTERA
FOS  ISETR  ECOA URSE
NO GISONE W .
ERAND TH AS E'BEEN
LKTA OF , WHDEVIOSHE HEETR
N  OHAD  OS,MISEMPCORO
ESE F  OTHMEN.
LL RWEEAKNN'Y DOT OROW F
SU
RD HI'VEEASE THE INTHM GS F
T ERDIFFENLEPEOP T BUIT
ERWOYOU ND TH WHEERYBAN
ELLYRE IS ANG GOI  BTO
LDLENTCCOUAB .
>>TI YOURE SNG GETLLTIIPS T
OU BOFT  THEE?LUEOE PL
US>> I JCOGOT T A S LEUP THI
WESE BEKECAUK HE T BOO I
G GETTINSSMESO PRE ND A I'M
G HEARINPLOMFR PEO ,SAE YING
.MEALLIN
I'EMAL CL TH L ALANIF SED E
IR THERUTH Y ANTR THETO
TI.PS
YOUY LLASWHENNO KW   Y
RY S ATOISE  LIKTHI ,
SAULWOD Y 90YBMAE  OCE PERNTF
EMT E ARNO GOODRMINFOION AT
GIF YT OU ETORONE WO  T
ATENT RCTHAKE  MA
FFDIONENCEER, HEE  TSIPI
TEGET D AF
SWAONTHE THABOUE T ST. E
ASOM ORAIRP.T
AIFIC TRCO HRONTLLER AD
EDLL ME ASD ANIT WD  F ARIEN
AIOF AN C TRR AFFIERNTCOROLL
WH HIMTOO LD THRA AIRAT TIC FF
ROLLNTERHASEEN H
MBARDISEPLANHIK S  A WIE TH
H OFBUNC IR GL.
TE W YOURIPT C THEHAER
THA OUE ABT  OCOUPF
TCLY SALKECT CHAHYRAS ER
YO DWHATO F KEU MA O , THATIT
E WAS ALE ST WTHEY
PLHED ORTE TY  JWERE, TUS
YOAT DWHO K U?
STTHE O Y ISOR S ZARRBIE,
IT'S MOYO LIKSTE 'TWOULU DN
ESEVE LITHTECHARE AC RS
ETUACALLYUTSTXIED BHE TY
IDALRELY D
THE IMYOW RK T  DESID A
STWHOLE T Y ORABOUICK PATR
LER KESSI KNICWHH  EWAS OUABT
AS UIT WNG BOLNFDI UTQU
LE TPEW OP D OLMETHY
GHTHT HEAS W IT
O NYFELO SSTI JU KE
INY  KINGWHIS YONETHE W
TIILS STL  IUIPURSNGT
CAE EV IHIERYTNG
G ARI
ATGAITOIN DETABL OUT W
HE ? UASP TO
>>D CLAIE MEID HADHE V.EO
TH HOMEH SOWD GOE TT EN
HOF  OESTHOSLOE NG-L
EPSTN DEVIAT OSTHE  HHAD
EITHEPEL HPED 'MEISTN, I
TRYIMBO  TREME TERHEILS DETA
.
D E HELPEIN EP ST
OR SLOTAG NG TETOMHI THO A
CTEF .
IT MADAS W AAME.UPE  N
HE ALASICLYOMEDSHOW S E OF
ESE LSSTILE M  FROTHO VIDE
HADTOE  OF  2TH
AT THRETEPRD IAVIRGIN
DUFRT  ANEND ITHPLIMIED  AT
ASTHIS W EIN FALLYNCE VI
ITGNST  THIM OFS  SHETATU
WAS VITHESE F SOOSDE OF ME
E ERTHESEN WUSMO M
DLGEYLVEDINVO
YTE  NEVHEDUCE PERROD
IT
LANTS WYERWAO ED T
THHETETICA TTHEO VIDS AT
CHA HIMEDE  D D ANH
EDODPRUCD M  THEAN JUHE ST
EASADIPP.RED
OUE  THTHWAGHT S
AJUWAS STNY PHO.
>> S WRIOUTEERALEV
RSARCHACTEOUHR TOUGHTHT E
OSOKBO, THTIALE LEGAS ON
R SADIPPEASTD ANALMOOUPL AE
Y TOFIMEST  SOUAY IMOALST
VEULCOD HATREE BN ENMEAPNT
. SOAL FROWYLAERS
NGUS SPECTEYTHYIER WE TR
TORANTP VID DADOYL
TED ESPRENVI ANDINRGIA
THSIS NEE MED REANTHE INMAS
SIS NEME OFANALITSH DEROWZ.
T RIAF HTHTER ATHENEAPPED
LE TIA MOONOUISIN H C
CA IN AGAST INVIRGIA,'SIT
SO PG THINISRICKAT
THSSLEKER T K ABINOUW HO
TCE HLIADO RIUS
MEHOSOW  TOBLHIKMAIACL OR M
RSHE H WHICLYS WAREAL MY
RESE CHMYAND EWNT IERVI
SHOWT HAWE NOS T THSECA .
WAS VIDAD G MELLTEIN TH
E. F AAK
NOW,OU Y KJUSTT' IS   I
E WHK INTHORY E OLST
ANNNE THESCOONECTIS INAND  RS
E IT ODDLEF   ALL
MEE THESWON EATHAT R Y HALLVE
FONEVER D UNICJUSTE.
S'S TATHEARDESTAD PT OUT AB
IHEHINK T T ARERE AC
O MESO HERASWYLAERS  WE LLYOU
.HTHD E RITHT ING
EMI THWHN O  K INIS GRANT
TO TIAUCL  TERS HIIN OMSF
CASESUL ITILEDHES  F D
FUHOLLY ADERE THRE, LE PEOP
REAWILLBOOKTHD E ND A ARNLE
.
GETT'RWEE G IN TNEARNDHE E
TIQUOUR ESONS BUT NE
HEOFEND  TU K  BOOYOTA
ABCKE T THREG ONIN
ATTHCHHA'S TT D R APTEAN
TH S, THMEE MEUNG YOWON
LYACTUALIT'S,  ATNOT THHEY  T
NDUTRETRIBHAN ORIO WVETER
EAEVEN H TNGLI BUT
. VEORAN OPPNITUTY
CA AU YOTALKT UTBO THA IN
CETHAT SCO INEN A TRUROOM?
I>>RIGHWAT S R EPAFT TE
N DI
ED
THEYAND GOINER WE IT TOG ,
JUS ST TALNORMLY KIHIS ND
RI HOFEANG A USIS JT
ITRMFOALY.
JUASIT W HEORST F TO GE JUD T
OPDR  ECATHE SELYTISSENAL,
ERWEREO RE NMOHEES CAS,
D DIHE BUTED TANUDGE J W
TOGIOM THEVE W AN EN
Y RTUNPOITOIRAY T SHE
KTO S, PE AB HT WHOUAT
HAED TENO TH EM
A QUISOTEOFUM NBER HE TM
FOEDOW UP IS HR EANGRI
RSTHD E FIYOTHT ING U
THCETI IS VE WEYERE  RY
SIMIHER LAIN TY AY W THE
CASED IETHEMESLV D ANEYTH
LOU EDOK, YO N CATELLEYTHAD H
MOES ASTPOUR NDEY WER
VEM LIST OD ANMOEMF
LONDREWE BE
T WASO I YOULIS KE OU CLDTE L
.
OOLLEY A LE ALKED IKD AN
WEY ANKLI E O NT TTHESLADI
OMAN TIMNEE I D D COUL
HEHEAR TG TALKM IN TO EACH
.THER
TH OE SO'RRT SAYIF NGAH, YE
I , MEMBREERU YO MEMBREER
TEY HTHADS HERTHEY,  W
STARRM TNGO FO TH FISALL
THEYTH BADEEN UGROH
G MESOTHINBL HSOORRIE
AGETOTHEROF SNDOME HE TM
T VENER MEERCHEA OTHEF BORE
KT BUTHEY OW NESOMETHF E
THIN,  GME WE THSAR THENOM O
NEL ORXWMAELKNEWHE TY
OPLEPEWEREHA TT OR IBIT
TH ANS HATADTHREWED R ORE DO O
DUSCHESOHELE TM REY  THEWE
GHCOHING TS OU MMONGRND
G D USANINPP TO ITSU T EAORCH
.THER
REY OLUTBSELLE TABO  TY
STAPWHATY  H NED PETO
EM, THNO SINT  THE
BUTADEILS HEJUT ST T RO PCESS
EYBUT THCTER WE VI THEIMY
ESWERE TVIFYTIING IMCTS
TTELAD TO  CHERIM
IN TINTHK RTRO CHEOU OM
DOZWEE REAT TS ENTHY H
HAD  FEWLYON AOT ND A N
IFYITEST THA, NGIST ?RIT GH
>>E QU WREERNUMBE ITA ER
WHT.
OFALNOT L ANEM TH W
TIIDENFEMTHHIESSELV WS CH I
'SITOTY  VEREML IONA
TH OK MY INBOF SOME,  OE TH
THORIESTS WE TOLEYD  RE
DOHORREN H ABOUSUT THEOWY
AKWERE TTA ADVENAN OF G
M ST TT ALUTNGKI ABO
SEXUEN BLYUT MLLTAY
ALE THMENT OSP AECTSTHF IS
T POIMRTAN AALMOSTANIMS PORT
AS A T ONCOMPEN WHAT
D.
HEMANILLTAY D THLAPUTE E
>>ETY SOA CI AWERG
ND MREMO AOUT E ORAB
ATRTUNFOUN.ELY
ISSTE S THLAN ST QUEIO
LIYONO I KW N  BU'VEEE
INSPDAALL Y N NGEAKI I
AMMII.
T T GOIRENGOVBE AO  M IE
? OIO NG YO PL TAY
>> S THERE' BINGOG TO
AMAD Y MCKACTE THDIRE IORS
G RK SON AIEERS, A
D LIMITEORRISEES FBO HOUABT
IT
E THI'D M HE G INWITH
.PTI
INBEG IEWETEINRVTHE ALD L
HEKE OS AYJOS GOWHN O'G INER
ME .LA PY
T KN.
BE M>>AYAREW A N CHEONEER T
.  REE
I'M RYNOT VEATRTIC AULAS E
U LLCAN TEISROM  FTH
TEW IE.
>> T GREOING NENO D ITOW
ANWATRI ULY AN TNTO THYOK U
FOK URYO WOR
VEYOU'BIAD ME A ENDIG FFER CE
YOU' GREOT G AAREEATR AND
SUREI'M 'S AHE TRE OT L I
W A FEVED YOANU'E VERC OOM,
PERYOURCE ISTSIENN
I S  OCOERMIES ATABSCL
A R S  IINL FOIOATNA
PLE  POFEO
ANLIURD JONACIESSTS PE ALLY
D COYOU ULONHAVEE  MUCH
ERLONG AN RI JUD ST OMMEECND
OKTHE BO FOY ANYBR ODD I AN
TO NTTHFOK YOANU INR G
USTOTHY FODAR Y  REAISLL
CORTANPOT ONERSANVTI
TWAK O TH TANDIOUEN
INANSAN FR OSCCIO ORINNLE
.RYUNTHE T COU
THM PROGRAAVLLWI BE
VIAS A POO DEAND  TASDCT OHE
WEBS.E
CO CWEONALTHB.LUORG.
I'M AND  ROSBERORT ANDTHENAL
NOTING MISEEEF  OTH
COTHWE CLU, B
D.URADJONE
EVODGO G.ENIN
PP US